make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin okay
so we are continuing on with our
avengers and our new avengers
yes we are we are continuing on
and uh in this one we pick up with the
kind of coming together
of the the teams right of the of the
illuminati and with captain america's
avengers team
sunspots avengers team this long awaited
sit down between these two groups
but the question people have is why now
right like why are we why are we just
now
calling a meeting like why why is it
that we're just now at this point and
why are things so dire
that reid richards and the illuminati
saw no other option than to basically
trap captain america's team
and then force them into a meeting and
and the reason why is because reed
richards kind of explains
that with everything that's going on
that while the the illuminati were
constantly on the run from captain
america's avengers team that they've
also been monitoring the multiverse
for multiple reasons right we saw that
earlier in the story they were
monitoring the multiverse to see if
there were other earths who found ways
to end the incursions or whatever it is
but one of the things that they realize
is that some kind of an event happened
out there they don't know what that
event is
but some kind of an event took place out
in the multiverse and where previously
you know despite how far into the
incursions we are there were hundreds of
thousands of universes left
now there's 22. something happened
there's 22 universes left and that's it
like no one like he doesn't know what it
is he doesn't know
what it was that had happened and when
the question's like okay so like
like what's the plan right like you know
when carol danvers like you know just
just tell us what your plan is reads
response is like
our plan for what what plan like i mean
there's there's no plan here like
there's there's no grit like i'm telling
you guys so you know what's going on
there's no great plan that i have i mean
i've got one you know one ace up my
sleeve but that's it
like like that's that's that's it like i
have one last like like literally one
last hope
like i have a singular hope out there
and that's it right that's that's all we
have
and when the question is like what have
you guys been doing all this time right
is what captain america asked you know
like what have you been doing
like what what's been happening here you
know what does all of this mean the
response of of reed and black panther
is okay well it looks like our odds are
better and when they're like well what
does that mean it's like we're gonna
miss every incursion except for one
the final incursion we'll outlive all of
them and when the question's asked like
well what is i mean what happens
right like what happens when we get to
the last incursion his answer is i don't
know like i literally have no idea like
i was hoping we'd never get to this
point i was hoping we would never get to
a place where we legitimately had to
face the fact that the multiverse was
going to end
but it's going to right like something
happened it sped up the
the death of the entire multiverse right
so now we're down to 22 universes left
they're gonna start crashing into each
other there's nothing we can do to stop
them
right like they're gonna start crashing
into each other we can hope that the
heroes on those worlds if that world
even has any heroes can somehow find a
way to stave it off but there's there's
nothing and then captain america's
response is like what have you guys been
doing this whole time right like i mean
sure we were chasing you guys down
whatever but you're the smartest man in
the world
what have you been doing if you say
you've been working on things and doing
things while you were on the run
what were those things and reid richards
kind of gives t'challa like this just
sad luck right and he says like you know
while she was our prisoner the black
swan
outlined some possible ways for us to
survive the incursions if the earth is
the incursion point which is to say
that if an earth exists in a universe
then if that unit if that earth collides
with another earth during
an incursion then like both universes
will be destroyed so we can do like so
many other people did which was to
destroy their world right destroy their
earth
and that would basically spare their
universe right like we can we can do
that we can see what happens and so
that's what they did right they
basically
created a cosmic cube and they created a
series of exodus planets right planets
within the universe where they could
basically start you know
like moving people right they could just
find these worlds there or they could
just make worlds right like they can
just create worlds out of nowhere
that are just habitable honestly because
it would take more time to look for a
world than it would be to just make one
and they could make a series of them in
like different solar systems or maybe
even an entire solar system that's just
colonized by humanity but the problem
with this
this is why i love jonathan hickman is
the stars are dying remember we covered
that in a previous video where we talked
about how you had those ex nihili and it
seemed arbitrary and i told you guys it
would become important later on that
those stars were dying out early that's
the problem that they have
because the universe is ending or the
multiverse is ending that means the
universes are basically going to end
sooner and the stars are just kind of
giving up right they're basically just
dying and so because of that like even
if they do have a series of exodus
planets there won't really be a star
there now they do have the ability to
create stars
right using using the cosmic cube the
problem is that with one of these uh one
of these you know suns going supernova
they had to get off like immediately and
they ended up leaving the queue behind
and the result was that the containment
device for the cube's energies was
destroyed the cosmic cube's energies
itself was not destroyed but the
containment device for the cube
was and so what they ended up doing was
moving on to the next thing right
because making a cosmic cube
is not an easy process and you need a
lot of energy and a lot of resources in
order to be able to do it and so what
they did is they moved on to the next
thing right they hit up the cosmic
entities they hit up galactus and they
ask galactus to arrange a meeting with
the celestials so that all the cosmic
entities could use their power to try to
create a habitable place right
explaining everything that's going on
saying hey guys i don't know if you've
known there's an incursion going on
there's incursions across the multiverse
right so an earth will pop
up and basically it'll sit there it'll
start moving closer and closer over this
over the span of eight hours and as soon
as it hits our earth both universes will
be destroyed we want to
basically evacuate the entire earth's
population right use your power
to basically create a world for us for
us to live on and then teleport
everybody on our earth to that new world
and then blow up our earth and save our
save our universe and the uh the cosmic
entities were on board
they were totally on board with it and
then they disappeared they just vanished
out of like they were just gone
why like why did they take off from
there like it turned into okay
like they they basically had brian
braddock hit up the captain britain
corps
and then basically go out there because
remember the captain written core is
multiversal so the captain written core
was exploring the source of the
multiverse but as soon as they started
exploring it they were met by the
arrival of the map makers and like they
were obliterated
pretty much everyone but captain but uh
brian braddock from the main marvel
universe was destroyed right they were
completely wiped out by the uh by the
map makers
and so then in turn reed richards turned
to franklin richards where he turned to
his son
to see if it was possible to use his
powers to create universes to somehow
create either a new universe for them or
to create a sustainable world but that
didn't work
nothing they did worked nothing worked
everything they've tried has failed and
it's every option that they have
and so when the question's like if we
don't really have a way to stop it like
are we any closer to figuring out the
cause of this right are we any closer to
figuring out
how these incursions are starting
because remember robert de costa sent
his multiversal avengers team out there
for the same purpose right but maybe the
illuminati have found something out and
reed says like we've we've tried quite a
few things and then suddenly he's cut
off and the reason why is because he
looks at everybody and says he's back
and this was the ace and the whole of
reed richards it's like okay who's back
like like who's coming back like who's
this one hope you had that's coming back
and he says you know like eight months
ago myself and tony like we
sent somebody out into the multiverse to
basically find the the source of the
incursions but he was only supposed to
be gone for a few weeks but like we
assumed he'd been lost forever
and when it's like okay like like he's
like he's returned like who is this is
ant-man
right it's hank pym like he's going by
the name yellowjacket now but like it's
ant-man and it's like he's like oh my
god i'm finally back and it's like okay
dude you're finally back like you're
finally here relax
chill for a minute but like tell us like
what did you find did you find rabu
milal do you succeed in finding him have
you found the great destroyer did you
find the cause of the incursions and the
response of of of
hank pym is no i didn't find the great
destroyer i found the ivory kings and
these
then they're like oh god like because
remember the ivory came to this mystery
group out there that are somehow
involved right we covered that in a
previous video
that the ivory kings are at war with
raboom allah and they're the other part
of the incursion
and so it's like okay like like
literally hank pym is just insane he's
out of his mind right just sputtering
like i found the ivory kings i found the
ivory kings right the white lords from
wild space from
out there from beyond i found the
beyonders all
hope is lost it's it's it's lost
there's nothing they can do there's
nothing they can do like it's the
beyonders right like any
chance of hope they had is completely
and totally
gone why is it gone we'll find out in
the next video
[Laughter]
we will find out in the next video uh no
we're not i'm not gonna leave you guys
hanging like that
i'm not gonna leave you guys hanging
like that because i know a lot of you
guys would be like no
like i need to know what happens next
okay okay okay
i'll tell you guys what happens next in
the next video with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comics explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core
if you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like
and i will catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you